alors voilà on va on a beaucoup de monde
sur notre plateau bonsoir êtes des êtres
vivants vous existez pour vrai
finalement généralement vous êtes
quelque part à l'étranger ou dans votre
contre et en abitibi très très loin ce
cas main témiscamingue pardon je ne faut
pas se tromper alors vous êtes là
préfèrent d'ailleurs la mrc de
témiscamingue claire bolduc diane bérard
christiane bergevin jean martin aussant
bonsoir à bout 4 merci donc de
participer à ce dernier c'est à 2,7 de
cette saison dans le fond parce que l'on
vient de vivre toute une saison au
complet on avait fait un spécial
également ca dans le temps des fêtes qui
ont en fait un autre pour terminer moi
j'ai le goût de vous entendre sur
l'événement économique de l'année
jusqu'à maintenant diom l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie c'est ce qui a
eu l'effet domino partout dans le monde
incluant québec ce n'est qu'on tourne à
exactement parce qu'il a eu des
répercussions sur l'inflation sur le
pétrole l'approvisionnement
l'agriculture et c'est donc au quai au
port forts signaux de lutte il est clair
c'est le projet de loi sur
l'interdiction d'explorer ou d'exploiter
des eaux carbu couplé à l'annonce de
2300 mégawatts
c'est une annonce québécoise sa place le
québec dans les leaders pour contrer les
changements climatiques sur le plan de
l'énergie ok intéressant jean martin va
sur plan des marchés si la fin de
l'argent gratuit parce que les taux
d'intérêt à zéro ce signifie que le
loyer de l'argent est à zéro donc c'est
d'argent gratuit c'est ce qui a mené à
l'inflation conte à la hausse des taux
n'était pas nécessaire et le rendement
économique qui va s'en suivre donc la
fin de la russie de grands événements
économiques effectivement christiane
japon dans même sens la spirale et tout
sens de l'inflation je trouve à 7.7 pour
ce service avec l'arbre et puis voilà
s'était chargée quand même cette
première moitié d'année je pense me
trompe pas là vous parlez de l'invasion
de de l'ukraine par la russie ya
tellement de conséquences et de
réverbération de ça on se demande
comment on va sortir justement les
chaînes d'approvisionnement
l'inflation également ok donc ça c'est
l'événement économique le beaucoup
économique christiane à ben moi je vous
dirais que la preuve le premier enjeu
qu'on a c'est la main d'oeuvre vous
savez la ratification par l'ontario à la
fin mars du programme de garde universel
au canada qui était piloté par madame
frieden qui fait que treize provinces
vont maintenant voir les territoires
accès à des taux plus abordable puis
vous savez au canada il ya deux millions
- deux femmes qui travaillent que donne
donc si on est capable d'augmenter la
main d'oeuvre en offrant des taux de
garderie épouse abordable est un gros
impact presque immédiat donc des
garderies à bas coûts comme ono qui
commande au québec depuis 1997
d'ailleurs il ya 5 % plus de femmes qui
travaillent au québec que dans le reste
du canada puis c'est directement lié à
la disponibilité des garderies dieu la
modernisation et l'élargissement du
système de conseil au québec qui est
éteint oui là je vous reconnais oui tous
besoin qui favorise la circularité parce
que l'avenir de l'économie par par la
circulation
[Rires]
ça veut dire que les matières premières
servent à fabriquer des biens qui
retourne à l'état de matière première
pour fabriquer d'autres biens donc on
fait une boucle alors au lieu d'avoir
une économie extractives pour lui
d'aller chercher tout le temps dans
maintenant première dans le sol on
réutilise le plastique devient la
matière première du plastique on
extérieur que plus de cuivre dans les
dépotoirs au canada et aux etats unis qu
dans tous les gisements connus alors
c'est de l'économie circulaire dont on a
besoin pour faire face elle ils vous
donnent beaucoup puisqu'il parlait le
branchement internet de tout le québec
branchement internet à haute vitesse
mais ils le font dette d'urgence aux pme
plus d'un demi milliard qui a été
consenti par le gouvernement du québec
et qui fait qu'on a actuellement le plus
bas taux de faillites au canada pour la
première fois ça a été très bien gérée
par les mrc
[Rires]
c'est sûr et merci font tellement un bon
travail jean marc tech mais si je me
place dans les souliers d'un
investisseur ça a été de rester cache en
fait les banques économique depuis le
début de l'année parce que les actions
ont baissé de presque 20% marché
baissier les obligations ont baissé de
10 % donc marché de collection ceux qui
étaient cachés ont battu tous les
marchés c'est à dire serait ce le cas
avoir de l'argent en enquête qui du lit
ou à quai ce pas mais pas été cités dans
des classes qui est décembre tout à mon
avis beaucoup duquel la plupart des
clients heureux sont ceux qui avaient le
plus de dents caisse
ok donc rester cash
pour rester cash le reste en année ça
dépend des claviers des actifs privés
qu'on peut ajouter un portefeuille qui
ne tienne deviennent
lagaf économique jean marais la guerre
économique à l'inversé ceux qui ont cédé
aux formes aux détenus fureur mais
signale donc tous français jean-louis
la peur de rater le train 10 ans et en
finançant travail vous connecter et donc
ceux qui ont investi dans tout l'est
tout au tout les titres qui étaient à la
mode sur les réseaux sociaux dans les
crypto en est qui ont perdu 70 % de leur
valeur en très peu de temps donc le fait
d'embarquer dans un train quand il est
déjà en marche c'est pas une bonne idée
donc ceux qui ont cédé à sa stèle
mauvais coup
certainement quelqu'un qui ont manqué le
train c'est le leader de candidat à la
chefferie conservatrice pierre poilievre
qui a proposé de congé dit s'ils étaient
élus comme comme chef du parti comme
premier ministre de congédier notre
gouverneur de la banque du canada qui
était pendant les congés des gourmands
n'avons pas vu l'inflation n'est hélas
ils nous montrent les taux d'intérêt
n'ont pas je pense qu'il faut respecter
il donne une chance de podium à haut
risque de faire serrer des roches par
plus d'un téléspectateur l'approbation
du projet b du nord donc ça va pas dans
le bon sens on se forme pas dans le bon
tempo si vous allez vous dire je ne
pouvais mais moi je parle avec mon carré
avec l'accord avec la province je pense
qu'il ne fallait pas prouvé ce projet on
ne va pas dans le bon sens il faut
réduire il faut pas augmenter faut pas
ouvrir le robinet il faut le faire mais
bon m'agace économique qui est
exactement dans ce sens là on a tous les
signaux le rapport du giec du mois
d'avril dit qu'on a très peu de temps
pour agir et on ne fait on ne va pas
assez vite on ne prend pas les décisions
assez rapidement où on prend les
mauvaises décisions comme vedior les
changements climatiques c'est quelque
chose qui va dépendre des gouvernement
des municipalités et des citoyens eux
mêmes c'est un bon en avant qu'on doit
faire pour contrer les changements
climatiques votre surprise économique
clair c'est quoi la rapidité de
l'inflation ne capte pas les signaux du
tout on a les capte pas et le 500 $ à
6.4 millions québécois
oui c'est nécessaire mais pas ceux
nécessaires pour certaines personnes oui
mais pas pour tous les niveaux pour 6.4
millions de québécois est pour moi la
rapidité avec laquelle l'inflation s'est
installée fin qu'on y réfléchisse qu'on
ait vu venir saucisse tune une surprise
économique comment fait-il qu'on la
capte pas les signaux et même que le 500
dollars 3 milliards 200 millions à 94
euros ce
matin votre surprise économique jamais
pour la première fois de mon vivant
puisque pas si vieux que ça mais j'ai
quand même une cinquantaine de canada
les etats-unis vont connaître une
croissance économique plus grande que la
chine donc ça c'est exceptionnel c'est
du jamais vu de mon vivant oui mais ça
bouge ans quand même les radiations mais
les confinements récent h et non
vraiment je ne m'attendais rnic ou d'un
cirque à l'est de la chine nation
chinoise fénié bleu ou cicad
ça c'est pas de surprise fonctionne
tout à fait mais pas surprise de deux
ans d'abord comment l'union européenne
peut imposer des mets
de boycott à la russie est resté
solidaire jusqu'à présent d'une vente
mais plus près de chez nous le rôle de
leadership du québec dans des projets
des grands projets d'attirer des
capitaux dans les grands projets reliés
à l'industrie de la batterie électrique
de la voiture électrique dont gm avec
posco kimiko qui portèrent les usines à
bécancour et basf la société allemande
alors chapeau on est en voiture et
dionne et bien la prise de conscience
étonnante de la part des élites
politiques et économiques qu'il existe
un lien entre les enjeux sociaux et les
enjeux économiques c'est comme si tout à
coup les élèves se réveillait disait 'oh
mon dieu si on pas de logement dans une
municipalité
on peut par des citoyens aux montures 6e
pôle logement on peut prévoir d'employés
dans une entreprise alors de ma carrière
de journaliste j'avais jamais vu son
corps et là tout à coup il y en a plus
de prise de conscience de ses élites
l'eau existent pour moi la reprise
économique or deux nouvelles
personnalités économiques christian
sophie brochu le projet champlain au
dessus de la ligne de transmission en
vue de céder son leadership absolument
jean martin mais moi c'est quelqu'un qui
est moins soûles et sous les feux de la
vente mais qui fait un travail
phénoménal c'est françois delorme une
économiste hétérodoxe connaître
qu'écornée contribué au g15 police qui
veulent définir une mesure au delà du
pib pour déterminer la prospérité et à
contribuer au projet l'école ensemble
pour le site indications plus juste ils
contribuent à des dix projets sur la
contrepartie aussi est-ce qu'on fait des
prêts des entreprises qui ont peu un bon
impact social et en plus il enseigne et
publier des livres fantastiques donc
chapeau françois de l'ampleur les
professionnels du développement local
qui ont fait le travail dans la dernière
année d'accompagner toutes les pme qui
font en sorte qu'on a un très beau taux
le plus bas taux de faillites au canada
mais qui ont aussi permis de d'apporter
un soutien concret à toutes les
entreprises avec les difficultés qu'elle
avait vécu durant la pandémie c'est une
équipe
gestion de votre personnalité qu'on
avait pensé à ça de moeurs sophie brochu
aux normes ou lavezzi with aids le
positif
alors moi j'y vais avec le givet avec
l'horaire rocha lhenry est la fondatrice
d'une toute petite épicerie zéro déchet
qui s'appelle beaucoup beaucoup qui
viennent d'avoir une subvention de 386
mille dollars de recyc québec alors ils
ont été éliminés 9,2 tonnes de déchets
depuis trois ans et là ils veulent aller
à 25 tonnes je sais que ça a l'air petit
mais c'est ça va dans le bon sens ok on
va terminer avec la citation de l'année
peu apprécié on aura les livres que vous
avez sur la table la citation de l'année
clair
c'est quoi votre citation de l'année gm
avait beaucoup surpris qu'on parle d'un
disque de pont par million d'habitants
ça m'avait énormément
regarde elle est l'heureuse élue c'est
ça mais surtout la construction du
tunnel sera elle-même carboneutre
beaucoup beaucoup d'arbres à planter ok
parfait c'est votre citation donc
jusqu'à maintenant de françois manardo
je suis dubitatif et avril 2022
christiane votre citation à vous par le
président de la commission économique
européenne ursula von der leyen bonne
prononciation des lieux c'est ça les
layènes vous avez bien raison on dit
alors que d'ibn changement climatique
c'est c'est un peu nous tous et on a la
responsabilité
d'ivoire est le gage et le pouvoir de
changer exactement alors c'est beau
c'est bien dit diom vous c'est une
déclaration de pierre olivier cyr le pdg
du clan panneton je tombe bien il
travaille pas mal de sens donc c'est
entrevue qu'il a accordée au magazine
urbania le pdg de clinquante penneteau à
10 60 % de mes déménagements sont des
évictions ok ça fait mal et donc la
situation est épouvantable montréal est
en train de perdre sa personnalité n'est
pas en train de s'en créer une ctri
s'ils font un plan parce qu'il va y
avoir plein de monde dans leur exacte
voilà la citation réfléchir bien sûr
jean martin vous moi ça date d'un petit
peu avant le début de l'année mais si
jean claude juncker le président dassier
président la commission européenne qui a
dit que face à la crise climatique et
aux crises sociales les élus savent très
bien ce qu'il faudrait faire mais ils
savent pas comment être réélu s'il le
faut
tout à la fois triste mais très lucide
puis comme il lui autour de la table
c'est un peu concernée
s'éteint c'est tout un défi ok parfait
on n'a pas fini parce que là vous avez
des livres maintenant on va passer à la
partie de lecture de notre notre ses
hôtes ce jeudi jamin jean martin aussant
vous proposez thomas piketty lecture
agréable sur la plage et oui en fait
pour cliquer et i will relativement
agréable parce que d'habitude c'est des
opus de 2000 pages les plus et ça c'est
un petit résumé de ses travaux sur les
raisons et les la lutte est aussi une
égalité qui on y voit en fait que c'est
pas une fatalité du tout il ya des
choses à faire pour réduire les
inégalités c'est un très bon livre est
très bref parce qu'effectivement thomas
piketty nous a habitués à des livres où
il ya énormément de recherches beaucoup
de travail indigeste oui
j'en ai lu un an parti qui du papier
bible finalement d'accès comme la bible
le déplie que ti sur les inégalités
l'historique de sa hockey thomas piketty
une brève histoire de l'égalité
christiane bergevin
jeremy rifkin absolument en français
l'économie de l'hydrogène et en anglais
des adultes jeunes économie et c'est un
livre imaginé de 2003 j'ai eues me
survivre cannes comme professeur et je
les relis j'ai commencé à le relire
parce qu'en 2003 vous savez quand les
sources d'énergie commence à diminuer
les civilisations qui en sont les
maîtres comment ça pourrait quitter à
tout point de vue c'est ce qui se passe
et ce qu'ils voyaient venir etc faut
trouver de nouvelles sources d'énergie
mais l'hydrogène ce qui est intéressant
plus de voyagement la grèce appartient
tout le monde l'air est composée
d'hydrogène et d'oxygène alors est-ce
qu'on n'a pas une source infinie dont la
propriété de vrai collectif spanc est
clair vanessa on n'a pas trop d'attentes
et l'hydrogène ben écoutez faut se
donner le temps mais c'est en 2003
n'avait commencé à investir comme on le
fait maintenant
peut-être qu'ici d'énergie sera
l'hydrogène alors excellente lecture
puis ça fait la genèse à partir de rome
jusqu'à maintenant c'est fascinant gros
caractères puis ça se lit en auriez
tension trick les gros ça va bien
l'économie
de l'hydrogène jeremy rifkin diane
bérard comment vous dites cela jean
privé jean tribu j'ai de la suite dans
les idées donc j'en privée de marie ce
terrain et antoine trussart mari est
conseillère municipale pour projet
montréal antoine et journaliste jean
privé avec le sous titre comment des
quartiers deviennent inabordables
donc ce que j'aime de ce livre c'est
qu'il est objectif c'est une histoire
objectifs de la gentrification et ça
parle du fameux point de bascule le
moment où on passe du de la cohabitation
de la diversité à la gentrification et
c'est très difficile de rester dans ce
moment béni où on peut cohabiter et on
bascule dans l'hymne abordabilité c'est
à lire ça se lit bien et ça parle de
plusieurs quartiers avec plusieurs parce
que la gentrification n'arrive pas de la
même façon dans tous les quartiers
saucier une leçon que j'ai retenue donc
le recommande je te prendre et claire
bolduc jacques attali jacques attali une
brève histoire là on avait une brève
histoire de galp et on une brève
histoire de l'avenir ce qui donnait une
conférence puis j'ai repris le livre
pour préparer la conférence à quel point
on n'apprend pas de l'histoire les
signaux sont là et les mêmes signaux ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui décrit ce qu'on
va vivre en 2050 en 2005 et pourtant les
signaux sont là on ne les capte pas où
on ne veut pas les voir c'est
regrettable
une brève histoire de l'avenir
prédisaient d'ailleurs en 2015 un
conflit où la russie la chine serait
associé et ou possiblement dire ans se
cirer à la russie et la chine alors je
regarde ça avec beaucoup d'attention ce
après on va mettre les suggestions sur
notre page facebook je le mentionne tout
de suite il nous reste quelques minutes
pour un quiz
voici le quiz de zones économiques du ca
c'est des questions très simples très
facile en principe vous est posée de
savoir ça qu'elle est hélas est promis
qu'ils répondent et vous allez à cumuler
des points pour
quel est le prix minimum d'un litre de 2
2% aujourd'hui 2 rennes 2 2 et une
baisse de 2 millions dans 98 non mais
non une 80 kg est qu on va le voir là
l'écran 3,60
pour ça que je suis ravie 3,78 de l'it
on oublie ça quel est le taux
d'inflation au canada
[Musique]
quel est le prix old quarter les le prix
d'un litre d'essence ordinaire au
centre-ville de montréal aujourd'hui de
12 hier soir
gagné 2,29 2 10 mais là il pue est
arrivé trop tard
régis faut pas pourquoi on met trop
rapidement je le donne à clerc celui là
il ya quelques semaines après l'annoncé
la fin de la production d'un petit
produit mythique lancé il ya 20 ans quel
est le nom de ce produit
2 à 1 pour que
vous jouez avec nous
quelques scènes publiques est devenue
vice présidente des communications du
canadien de montréal en janvier chantal
j'étais dans le match 10e
omar ce qu'elle annonce 6 milliards 400
millions touchant le transport en commun
de montréal a été faite par le grand
john ridding le prolongement de la ligne
2 du métro toute une remontée de
l'excellent pour que ça se fasse
forcément oui ça va se faire bien sûr ça
va se faire quelles mesures du dernier
budget du québec a été mise en place
pour aider une grande partie de la
population à contrer l'inflation
tout le monde un point tout le monde à
quel coût peut-on prendre un aller
simple montréal rouyn noranda depuis
déjà trois semaines c'est
simple je vous fais je vous fais le pari
de le trouver le billet sec sandales à
250 dollars lysiane le point est une
belle explication quand même pas facile
comme le passeport quelle entreprise
pharmaceutique a annoncé l'installation
d'une usine bernina way
madione s'inscrit au pointage
le réseau des réseaux si tout se passe
comme prévu à quel moment le troisième
lien entre lévis et québec serait-il en
activité de 1075
2030 rail 2030
j'étais proche
- christiane quel terme est utilisé
était utilisé par le premier ministre ou
d'eau pour qualifier les influences aux
abois jean martel aimant dernière
qu'elle est la population du canada à
200 milles près 38 milliards 38 millions
et 27 millions 137 millions 8 dyane
match et toutes les bonnes réponses non
non donner votre réponse et coiffes 37
millions ça bon ben si vous quittez 1,8
million 528 mhz et 700 donc le pointage
est de combler parce que moi j'ai perdu
un peu le corps parce que christiane et
première non et je pensais que jean
martel
je vais gagner mais lorsque le chien des
tables attention le voici jean martin 3
claire bolduc 3 christine danjou et 3 et
john de lasse
c'est marrant ton est devenu passeport
la bonne nouvelle
merci à vous quatre un plaisir qu'on va
vous retrouver au mois d'août pour notre
nouvelle saison vous continuez dans
notre ca c'est un bonheur de vous avoir
donné tes merci bonus
venez voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d